Amazon shares jump overnight after
earnings went beyond the company's own
expectations the stock price gained more
than seven percent in after-hours
trading Amazon just reported forty three
point seven billion dollars in quarterly
sales that is up thirty four percent
from last year the world's largest
online retailer bought Whole Foods in
August now it is reportedly looking to
make a move on drugstores CBS News
Financial contributed Mellody Hobson
joins us melty good morning good morning
so what are they doing this making all
this money Wow
it was a quarter I mean it was
unbelievable people were expecting three
cents a share in earnings and they
reported 52 cents a lot of is the sales
growth record revenues in a non holiday
quarter but one could say it was
Christmas in July because it was that
prime day in July that really boosted
revenues especially with prime date
taking off internationally and the whole
field Whole Foods deal apparently had
nothing to do with this money not really
they're saying about 1.3 billion dollars
in revenues came from Whole Foods after
the deal closed it kicked in a little
bit on profits but the really story is
not what holds Foods is today it's what
it's going to be I went into a Whole
Foods in Los Angeles yesterday the first
thing I saw with those arrows on lockers
where you can ship your packages there
so that story is still to come
well now they're going from Whole Foods
to wholesale pharmacy license in a dozen
states they want to get into the
pharmacy business and that's now talking
that leading into this CVS Aetna deal I
mean just what would what would have
Amazon be doing well I think this is a
brilliant idea I mean it's a natural
extension to go into drugs and also drug
wholesaling because they have such a
great logistics model that they can take
advantage of and it has the drugstore
chains worried when it was announced
that they were going in down this
direction their stocks did sell-off and
so they're looking for other means of
growing and so that's why I think we saw
the CB CBS Aetna announcement as well as
the fact that the government says we
don't want any more of these drug stores
tying up together they did not allow
Walgreens Alliance boots to buy Rite Aid
so what else might they go into well who
knows I mean they have had logical
extensions of what they do I think
they're going to maximize this whole
suit Whole Foods purchase and really
bring this brick and water and law
online together I think there are a lot
of synergies there still to come and so
that's what I would be watching very
very closely the private label business
so Whole Foods the cloud industry maybe
pharmacies is there any concern from
anybody that outside of Amazon that they
may be taking on way too much I think
there's always that concern
anything can happen this is not going to
be straight up I think they're gonna you
know stub their toe from time to time
that's for sure but what they've done so
far is really really smart and they
haven't been acquirers Whole Foods was
very unusual for them to do that deal
everything else has really been a
function of serving their customers
they've got all that competitor they've
got all their competitors turned you see
Walmart you know rapidly trying to get
its online machine up to speed and one
could say they're making retailers
better all right so we're gonna see Jeff
Bezos on top of another turbine breaking
open that champagne bottle we know he
knows how to do that that's right
all right Mellody Hobson always good to
see you thank you so much for joining us
this morning